kiss time but your goal is pretty
breathtaking you want nothing less than
to end the idea that your background
determines where you go in life you say
break in that link that's what Labor's
for I've always felt that it runs deep
for me but it's hard isn't it to see
that ambition as more than warm words
without a revolution in resources for
the state sector isn't the truth that
it's not something that you
while promising now will be in a
position to deliver anytime soon that's
the reality isn't it look the reality is
I'm utterly committed to this we're
setting out five missions for government
this is one of them so this is one of
the big things that we want to change
and I'm determined that we will break
that link the pernicious link between
for children young people between where
they start in life and where they end up
and the idea that in 2023 in the UK the
earnings of your parents determine still
more where you're going to end up than
your own Talent is something that drives
that determination in me and that's why
we set out in terms today
and I think everyone heard the ambition
loudly the point I'm trying to make to
you is that it has to be Evolution not
Revolution because you simply don't have
the resources to deliver it fast is that
fair though these things will take time
I've not pretended this morning that we
can snap our fingers on this what I do
know is that if we work at the this over
five years or more of the next Labor
government and we're absolutely clear
that this is our priority we can make
the changes some of them we can start
very quickly so for example we need more
teachers qualified teachers in maths and
science at the moment if you advertise
in some places for a math or science
teacher you get no applicants so we've
got to change that and get them in and
the idea of parents having children who
don't have a teacher that they know
needs to be in the classroom with them
that's not acceptable we need to retain
the teachers that we've got and we need
to think more about what we call oracy
this this ability to speak confidently
which we know is a massive barrier
particularly for children young people
not just at school but you accept the
point that it has to be Evolution not
Revolution given that you cannot provide
a revolution and resource in the first
two years of a labor government I mean
you accept that right where we've made
commitments
um we've set out the funding for that
and that can be put in place yes
straight away but we're going to go at
PACE on this I want this change to come
about and I know that but then you won't
commit more resource the whole point you
won't commit more resource I asked you
and you you I I made the point about
what the association of head teachers
said schools need significant resource
you won't commit it well look do we need
resource more resolved for our Public
Services yes do we need to grow our
economy to get to that place yes that's
why this Mission and the mission for
growing our economy goes side by so
reform fast funding later well we need
to do both at PACE these missions are
intended to operate together but do I
want better resource Public Services yes
I do do I understand that we've got a
damaged economy under this government uh
you know they've barely grown the
economy for 13 years they then had the
Kamikaze mini budget that did even more
damage We'll Inherit that if with
Provisions but we have to be clear what
is it we're trying to achieve because
then we'll have to make difficult
decisions and the missions are intended
to be a way of saying that is what
matters most to me that's what drives me
will pull our resource there
you you talk about a class ceiling you
want to get State schools to the same
level as private schools by when well as
soon as we can and that's the first time
of the labor government takes two labor
governments takes a generation by when
that this is intended to set out what I
would hope to have achieved in five
years of a labor government maybe a
little bit more we're in a bad situation
a bad starting situation but you're to
go back to where you started I I want
um State schools to be just as good as
private schools I want parents to feel
that
um you know it doesn't matter anymore
whether you send your children to state
or private school because the quality of
Education because it is as good in both
places and to give children into State
schools the same opportunities as they
have in private school the gap between
state school funding and private school
fund this is an ifs document up to the
year 2021 a bit out of date it's it's
doubled in the past decade
it's from three and a half thousand
pounds to six thousand sorry 310 six and
a half thousand pounds you just can't
close the gap can you in a one term well
look I think we can firstly set out what
we'll do in the immediate um first step
which is to remove the tax break for for
uh public schools and use that money
directly to support uh children young
people in our state schools but it's not
all about money there's the reform issue
here as well when we're talking about
the curriculum and the difference it
would make for children young people to
be able to express themselves clearly
with confidence in the school in the
workplace that will make a massive
difference to their lives so yes money
is an issue we will have to make tough
decisions but reform is also an
important part I'm jumping in because I
haven't got much time in 2006 uh Gordon
Brown uh committed to increased State
School spending up to levels of private
schools that was a commitment you might
not be able to do that in the early
years of a labor government will you do
it later is that an ambition of yours at
least look it's always an ambition of a
labor government to make sure we got the
best possible education and and have
properly funded Public Service my
question was would you commit to getting
spending levels up to private school
levels in a labor government you might
not that that's the question we do need
more funding we will have to grow the
economy we're going to inherit a very
badly damaged economy what I've set out
is what steps we're going to take now
how we're going to fund them what we're
going to do to grow the economy and and
I would reflect back on the last Labor
government all labor governments improve
education standards build schools and
that will be the ambition of the next
Labor government just as it was at the
last level it's new teachers you want to
recruit six and a half thousand but
retention is terrible one in five
teachers who qualified in 2020 have quit
according to government figures labor
figures more than a third of teachers
who qualified in the last 11 years have
quit so will you give teachers the 6.5
pay rise recommended by the pay body if
you want to retain them you need to pay
them properly well look if I was in
government I'd make sure the education
secretary was in the room talking to the
unions right now to resolve this dispute
but you know you talk about retention of
teachers quite rightly what we want is a
framework for progression to recognize
their qualifications and also a
retention payment for good teachers who
stay in the classroom uh over the two
years I think a hearing is that you
won't commit to it so you want to retain
them but you won't you won't commit to
giving them the pay rise that the
independent body recommends that's what
they hear we don't know what the body
has recommended yet we're in 6.5 we're
in opposition not government the
government needs to get around the table
and resolve this issue so I think most
teachers most parents would be pretty
astonished to know that they're running
out so teachers will be teacher we hear
the leader of the labor party won't
honor necessarily pay recommendation I
think teachers will be hearing from
today as will parents that there is a
core commitment from labor to education
if we come into power just as there was
last time there's another group of
people might be felt feel let down by
you and that students you promised when
you became partially to use scrap
tuition fees it was in two labor
manifestos you've broken that promise
well I think the tuition fees regime has
to change I don't think it's fair and we
intend to change it and come forward
with our plans for doing so but look
there are there are good labor things
which we will not be able to afford to
do because of the damage this government
has done to the economy and that's why
I've been clear in my missions by saying
these are the priorities these are the
big changes that we need to see for our
country
most important of which is growing the
economy and lifting living standards
across the country
if it wasn't for the pandemic would you
reintroduce that policy or you think
it's dead well look we need to look at
the finances as we get closer to the
election there's probably I don't know
two maybe three fiscal events yet we
don't know what we're going to inherit
but you know we will sell out our plans
the current scheme is not right we will
set out our plans as we go forward